I've been a lover of the queen since a  little girl growing up I didn't have any  grandparents present in my life so I've  always looked at the queen as a really  personal person in my life she's really  played that role of Grandma before me  not only the service that she sent her  for us as a country in the Commonwealth  but for me personally and like I was  saying she's given 70 years if not more  to us so if I can't give a couple of  hours then what can you  and just interestingly your level of  attachment to the queen is is very  clearly on your arm there you've got at  least one tattoo  the whole art the whole arm is clean  related wow wow so I mean it must have  hit you quite hard then yeah on a  personal level yeah it was really really  tough luckily I've got a strong family  and friendship Network and they knew  when this day came that they should have  to Rally around me and they have my  support Network's been fantastic so